it becomes like you've got sort of uh a
slot machine on your desk and you just
keep putting quarters in and pulling the
handle you know
you can't get away with this over and
over again like this was
really a bit of a one-off or at least
it's it's a it's we're not going to see
20 years of a group of guys
picking a stock squeezing it making
money and moving on to the next that's
not how it's going to work
ladies and gentlemen welcome to
coffeezilla today we are talking to
patrick boyle
yet again you guys probably know him if
uh you've seen this channel before we
put a great interview up here you should
go watch it after this video
but today since there's so much interest
i thought we'd do
something of a i don't know patrick i'd
maybe call it a
post-mortem on gamestop talk about new
traders
uh what you can learn from this
experience a lot of people maybe got
into stocks for the first time i know a
lot of people open their first robin
hood account
and we should talk about all of that but
first thanks for coming back
thank you it's exciting to be back it's
always fun
do you think it's appropriate to se to
say that uh the game stop
sort of big rally the big mo movement is
mostly over i think it probably is like
it i i kind of view this as a bit of a
tug of war where there's
two groups kind of pushing and pulling
well pulling
and eventually it sort of has to go back
to a normal market state and
there's i i was kind of thinking about
this earlier there's
there's a feeling amongst one group that
if um
you know if they pile in and hold on
that the price will go up and up and
stay up but of course
the price gets pushed up when there's
more buyers than sellers right on
it's sort of like more buyers than
sellers over time
i guess or at least more demand to buy
than sell
at a given point in time and so you're
able to push it up like this but the
problem is eventually you run out of
steam
buying and unless you buy up the entire
float of the company
it eventually has to it's sort of the
marginal buyer and seller who set the
price of anything and so
it eventually has to return to a value
at which
someone is buying it for ownership of
the company like to to sort of
receive the cash flows associated with
owning a
company like this rather than to be
involved in the squeeze
obviously this is one of the big
questions right a lot of people
have you know know that most
institutional investors believe the
short thesis
there's obviously people on wall street
bets who are
at like like deep value for example who
believe sort of in the
the chance for a lot a long you know
bullish case for gamestop do you think
that's
correct or do you think that's mostly
just you know the truth is i don't have
any like
real analysis of the underlying stock
like i
i because what's happening here is
unrelated to
the fair value of the stock at the
moment it's just it relates to
market mechanisms uh you know tied to a
short squeeze
and tied to an ability of people to pile
in like
you know i i spoke to tom nash a while
ago
and he argues that the stock is worth
we'll say 30
you know i i don't know if that's true
or not
but um you know i i wouldn't necessarily
say that the
the short view is is right either
but if people are arguing that the
reason that the price drifted down was
that this stock was ignored by wall
street that no one did any
real research on it and they just let it
fall well you know the truth is over the
last week it's gotten more uh
analysis probably than any other stock
in the
in the world and so it's no longer
uh sitting in a condition where you can
argue that
the price is low because it's not uh not
being paid attention to
interesting so i think one of the things
that i want to talk about
is retail traders obvi i i had a lot of
friends
come to me i mean i'm not at all
a sophisticated investor i very early
kind of learned the lesson of
if you don't know what you're doing just
put something in a vanguard fund or one
of these etfs and just kind of like
let it be you're gonna lose money you're
probably gonna lose your money otherwise
if you're just trying to take your uh
wealth into your own hands there
but i was approached by a lot of my
friends who
i mean shockingly know even less than me
about
about investing which is saying a lot
and they were
they were talking to me they go well you
know you kind of deal in this stuff
sometimes stephen right which
it's not really true because i mostly
talk about scammers i don't talk about
trading but
they said you know kind of where do we
start this is our first experience
with robin hood or one of these types of
activities
where where would you start i mean would
you say that most
people let's just assume they don't want
a career in trading
i mean is it safe to say just buy etfs
nobody wants to do it because it's
boring
you know it's even worth just looking at
like you can go down to your local
bookstore and find some of those kind of
boring
personal finance books and they'll just
even explain to you
like the simplest things like the
difference between investing in stocks
and bonds how they perform
how does investing in real estate and
things like that work
out and and sort of prudent financial
approaches you can take like how to
invest in a tax efficient manner
you know whether you should even be
investing at all if you've got debt like
are you better off paying down your debt
or investing and that's really where to
start like you don't need to start with
really complicated ideas of like
arbitrage strategies or understanding
short squeezes or anything like that
like you
at first probably just need to come up
with a basic financial plan and even
work out like what are your goals for
investing like if if you're your age is
your goal to
sort of try and grow rich in the next
few months that might be hard
but you know if your goal is to set
money aside for retirement you maybe
even just want to work out
how much money you'll need at retirement
and how much you need to set aside in
order to do that
that's one of the complicated uh factors
here
which is that and this is something that
i really want to get into
which uh robinhood which i i'm not going
to get into why i'm a little frustrated
with them right now
but they've they've really uh among many
other online brokerages
have offered retail traders basically
pretty sophisticated financial
instruments we'll call them um
with very little requirement for any
knowledge of how to use them and i feel
like
i'm talking to people who they didn't
know what a stock was last week and
they're doing you know
margin trading or uh you know it's kind
of
is that is that a bit ridiculous it
really is
uh you know the worst thing is i i
sometimes feel that i sound like such a
prude when i
i chat with you about this stuff because
there's lots of people in the comment
section they're like this is so boring
but
you know if you're setting money aside
for your retirement it's probably not
meant to be that exciting like it should
be about as boring as
as it sounds you know like you're
setting money aside and you're hoping to
grow
it at a given rate um the problem
actually i had a really
interesting interview on my channel um
it's actually the most recent video i
did it was a guy called victor hagani
who was
one of the partners at long-term capital
management i don't know if you have you
heard of long-term capital management
well they were um kind of the biggest
hedge fund in the 1990s they were kind
of the biggest smartest hedge fund
they had uh scholes and merton were
partners at long-term capital management
these are the guys who
developed a pricing method for options
right
and so it was kind of the nobel prize
winner
hedge fund you know and in 1998
everything went horribly wrong there was
a russian debt default
and these guys had basically built some
very complicated trading strategies very
very smart stuff in truth but it's
almost like
the first boat that was pushed out into
the ocean you know and so it went
it went horribly wrong and they lost all
of their money on their
investors money um but you know once
again smart guys but the problem is they
had nothing to base it on because no one
had done the kind of stuff that they
were doing before
and a lot of the lessons in there are
kind of down to things like
leverage and derivatives causing
problems and so
uh the the guy victor he is he he was a
partner there
and obviously you know his he was kind
of dragged through the mud in the press
as you can imagine like it was a
massive massive disaster at the time and
he since then went on and worked out
well how does he want to
invest and he now has a much more
conservative approach which is largely
an allocation to stocks and fixed income
based on a few things like the level of
interest rates and a few other things um
that that's really just
uh you know a very boring like i i don't
mean that it's boring but i mean that
if you think like this is a guy who is
as sophisticated and investors you can
think of and and this is his approach
like it's not um
you know and then you have these young
people and they're like well i'm gonna
make you know
two percent a day and you know that
that as i mentioned in the last video it
doesn't tend to work out for people
yeah i mean well and i consistently get
people who say oh wow this guy just
hates day traders huh oh he just hates
day traders because
and they go look uh you know if you have
less than a million dollars it's easy to
make a hundred percent
200 a year consistently
and i try and i always ask like oh well
have you done it
and if they say yes they go for how long
and they go well i'm on track you know
this month
all right well show me the next show me
the next
10 years let's see how you perform you
know in the comments on on the last
video that we did there were a lot of
people and they kind of
they were a bit angry at the idea that
we said this and they go well if you
invest in crypto you know it moves a
huge amount a day so you can definitely
make
that amount and it's like well you can
make or lose that amount you know that's
what you have to remember it's the more
volatile
like gamestop is more volatile than a
than a more uh what can i say a more
state
sort of a stock that you invest in and
so yes you could have a thousand percent
return or you could lose
all of your money you know and in fact
if you're using leverage or derivatives
you can lose more money than you have
and so
it's not um you know these things are
whatever people want to say like you
know in the last video just to be clear
i didn't say people can't make money as
day traders i just said that it's
unlikely and it's particularly unlikely
that you'll just sort of drift into it
with no background and just sort of
instinctively know what to do
that's right i mean um i i think there's
such a downplaying
of expertise background
you know when taking into account what
makes a trader successful and it's more
like oh yeah you just kind of try it for
five years
and you stick with it and then you
become successful at day trading it's
like that's not
you look look at a lot of these people i
mean i i remember just more generally
uh because i i've heard all these people
saying like quit your job blah blah
and when you look at the most successful
people in the world overwhelmingly they
are first college educated but then even
more overwhelmingly
ivy league educated and just like
high class education correlates highly
to
high levels of success the same is true
for day trading if you are
you did not go to college and
specifically you did not go to college
for finance
as like a bear bar minimum the chances
of you becoming a successful day trader
is low it doesn't mean it can't happen
but it means you're fighting
so far upstream it's kind of insane and
i think
part of the problem is that there's so
much to know in the financial markets
how do people even get started because
it feels like what
what you don't know can hurt you in the
financial markets
where you can think you kind of got a
grip on things but actually you're
missing
tons of context about how market forces
work i think we we actually saw this
with
you know robin hood halting trading and
uh a lot of people myself included were
very
angry about that then all of a sudden
you learn more context about how
robin hood even makes its trades how
collateral is
at the in scc or whatever and it's like
yeah a lot of people didn't know that
before it's
interesting because even things like you
know the last week has been a really
interesting week in markets and
you know because i teach about
derivatives at a university i will be
using this as an example for years to
come because there's so many interesting
things that actually happened
but even that idea of expertise i was
listening to the radio the other day
and there was someone on there's often i
guess there's two ideas there's one
group of people who sort of say
no one is an expert everyone
instinctively knows everything
and then there's another group who sort
of says i only listen to experts
personality both are a little bit wrong
if you know what i mean because i was
thinking that
even if you are an expert like i know
quite a bit about financing that i've
left i've spent
quite a lot of my time studying it
learning it working in the industry but
i'm constantly learning new things like
even last week with a lot of what was
going on
you had to really learn about like how
certain areas of markets work and so
you know if if someone quickly asked me
what was going on i couldn't necessarily
give a great answer and i found myself
speaking to other people who understand
maybe more of the nitty-gritty technical
details of how
how markets work like even just the
nature of margin you know because
there was a lot of confusion around the
idea that robin hood had to post-margin
um at the clearing house
and a lot of people said well you know
their customers had the money in the
account
and therefore they should be able to
post that as margin but that's not
actually how margin works so
a broker has to post their own money as
margin you can't post customer money as
margin
until the settlement date you know and
there's these all relates to things like
all the basal accords and all sorts of
rules of how markets work and it's not
necessarily
intuitive and when you see this sort of
thing happening you know it it did look
rather weird you know when you see
that they couldn't do you know that they
couldn't take certain types of trades
but actually
the the explanation makes an awful lot
of sense but once again
you need almost a deeper level of
expertise when things get really weird
like they did last week
now obviously robin hood uh
suffered kind of a pr disaster from that
i think in part
though it wasn't just the fact that it
was complicated it was also
their answers seem to kind of i don't
know
triangulate towards the answer that like
weebles ceo gave um pretty much
immediately
robin hood's ceo kind of was like i
don't know was there liquidity issues no
there's no liquidity issue and it's like
wait if there's no liquidity issue you
should have just posted the collateral
um so i i guess my question is
when when you look at robin hood and
you're thinking of you know
trader like if you're just you know
regular trader
are you looking at anything that robin
hood did recently as any sort of
indication of a problem or you're just
like
you know what it was what what we might
call an outlier event uh
probably not going to happen again
you're basically fine and robin
it it's hard to say you know robin hood
basically has that sort of startup feel
to
it in that they well they're kind of a
bit of a silicon valley startup slash
brokerage firm and
it's interesting like because obviously
if the ceo had come out and said
yes the reason we're stopping people
from buying these stocks
is because we have a liquidity problem
you can't say that in the financial
world you say the word liquidity problem
everything gets pulled out you know like
all accounts get closed in 10 minutes
you know
so he didn't want to say that
and then it's kind of an interesting
thing because obviously he
they needed more capital and in truth
actually they were able to
i think they had to raise them like
three billion dollars and
i believe up until that point in time
the entire capital they brought in was
around 2 billion so they had to
really increase their capital base and
they managed to do it rather quickly so
you could make an argument that actually
they you know did there didn't they have
a liquidity problem
it might not be a liquidity problem if
you're actually able to bring in
three billion dollars with almost no
notice you know so
it's hard to um to know how to
characterize that and i think
one of the problems that that robin hood
has
is that they they slightly have that you
know
silicon valley startup kind of fake it
till you make it
vibe and you know that's even why they
ran
into trouble with the sec a little while
ago like
it wasn't even that it wasn't they
weren't specifically
doing anything that wrong or that
unusual
it's that they weren't telling their
customers the truth like
it was all about disclosures you know
like and it was
you know i i don't know really what to
say about that like
it it possibly just is the nature of
these sort of
startup type firms like that that you
know
things are always maybe a little bit
held together with uh you know duct tape
and coat hangers in the background and
that can from time to time be a problem
it seems like they were trying to like
kind of scale as fast as possible
and maybe there wasn't as much attention
to
like due diligence and stuff like that
um
with their case though i i don't know i
was reading the sec filings the other
day
and it was it seemed a bit more than
like
oops we forgot to tell you what 80
percent of our revenue was and it seemed
more like
we don't like how this makes us look
given our mission statement of robin
hood being
sort of for the people but then we're
actually
kind of making money well the the thing
they got in trouble for as i recall like
so
a lot of people are confused and they
think that robin hood
invented this idea of payment for for
order flow
well i think that was bernie madoff
right bernie madoff actually came up
with that
within his non-uh the non-fraudulent
part of his business
um but the the thing about
robin hood was they they did uh
bring bring commissions to zero which
was probably something that was going to
happen anyhow and they
sort of pushed this ahead but i believe
the the sec complaint um and actually if
i'll i'll
you will you have a link to it maybe
throw it in the description below for
people to read
but i think the way the sec complaint
looked at it was
that they they did this payment for
order flow thing they were taking
more payment for order flow than the
other brokers were
and i think it turned out there was a
number something like
34 million dollars that they they
basically i think
that customers as a group would have
been 34 million dollars
better off if they'd paid commissions at
a
another advanced execution
rather than getting the sort of free
trades at robin hood and i i think even
in
in my prior chat with you we we talked
about this idea that
you you shouldn't really expect anything
to be so free and
you know if someone's giving you a
service and it's free
there's there's something wrong like
you're slightly uh
to blame as well for almost expecting
that to be a realistic
yeah yeah yeah event well it's it's from
the internet being on the surface
everything's free right on the surface
it's free to use google on the surface
it's free to use youtube
right you're being monetized in a way
that is not
um so visible and so yeah i think that's
that's led to sort of this idea of like
oh we're kind of getting this for free
when well and even in in the
you know last sort of 10 20 years
there has been this almost like well
we'll say a company like uber like uber
loses money every time you use
one of their their taxis you know
and um and that's sort of their way of
growing and there's
a lot of people have gotten used to this
idea of
this silicon valley business model that
that you can sort of buy
a dollar for 90 cents and that that
seems to appear in the world from time
to time while some of these companies
grow with huge amount of venture capital
funding but of course
there is a long-term goal at any of
these businesses to eventually prep
flip to profitability and i i guess
maybe a a younger cohort than me
see this and actually it just doesn't
seem as wild to them that someone will
give them something for
for less than it it costs to manufacture
but
that's not a reasonable long-term
expectation
so returning a bit to gamestop i think
one of the interesting
uh dynamics that we haven't seen
i guess in quite a while is this sense
of
sort of and true or not because some
people have challenged the idea that
this is such a clean narrative
but of the retail trader versus the big
bad hedge fund
right um sort of the idea that you know
there are these bad guys out there
shorting these companies these american
companies wanting them to go to zero
and basically the retail trader gets
wind of it plays them at their own game
um and then you know the rest is history
sort of do you think that's a fair
narrative interesting thing you know
well it is interesting because the
there was something very smart about
that trade and about the
you know a lot of people early on were
saying is it market manipulation is it
you know is there a legal trading
activity
and it doesn't appear to me that there
is because you know often
within a legal trading activity there
sort of has to be a lie being spread
like where someone says
that there's some you know a pump and
dump scheme it usually involves
taking a position in the stock and then
spreading a lie that the company is
better than
people think it is but that wasn't
really what happened people
pointed out a fairly truthful fact that
there was a very large short interest
and eventually these shorts have to
cover
and should a squeeze occur it causes
real problems for them and that is
exactly what happened but then there was
this other
weird um what would i call it like a lot
of people were trying
tying it into the um what were those
no i can't even think of the name of it
the wall street occupy walls occupy wall
street and they were
throwing on this sort of political layer
that didn't actually make sense like a
good trade is good trade a bad trade is
a bad trade
there's no uh you know there's no real
um
morality to to either being right or
wrong on the trade it's just so that the
it's about being more right than the
other person or even sometimes just
being luckier than the other side
that's that's funny i bet that's
probably truer than most people think
uh getting uh having a luck on your side
um
oh there's one other thing i i sorry to
interrupt but sure there's one other
idea that was out there that i i thought
wasn't
very helpful was there was this idea
that that it's kind of pushed a little
bit by elon musk the
idea that you can short a good company
to zero and cause it to go bankrupt
and that doesn't actually make sense
because
the a company issues stock at
certain points in its growth in order to
bring in capital in order to grow a
business so
it's kind of like if you sold shares in
coffee zilla
in order to buy a 10 million dollar
studio to grow uh
to grow the audience now
when that stock is sold that's when the
money comes into the company
after that the price that it trades at
is irrelevant to whether the company
stays in business
now that's why even companies
incentivize management like they either
give them options or they give them
shares or they try and get them to buy
shares because they want to align the
interests of the management with the
shareholders
but in truth if you look at a great
company it could have a share price of
zero
and still stay in business because a
company goes bankrupt when they can't
pay their bills
right not uh no point their share price
goes to zero i think that's a great
point that yeah thanks for adding that
um what do you think about so so
this is the tough thing about wall
street bets for me because
on the one hand first of all it's just a
blast to look at these guys are
hilarious i think that
like cannot be overstated but secondly
um you know obviously there was kind of
a good idea behind the gamestop thing
but unfortunately i had a lot of people
come to me sort of
the the mo when the most people were
coming to me about like oh i'm
investing in gamestop was sort of at the
worst possible
time i mean like at like when they were
getting to 300 and everyone
had already heard of it everybody who
like was gonna make money on this had
already kind of invested in
but there's this idea of um like
i mean you know diamond hands right you
gotta just hold on you hold on no matter
what
if you're this is the tough thing
because it's it can seem a little stupid
to take a joke
seriously and if you do take it
seriously they're like well it's just a
joke
but i do i do get the sense that some of
these investors like really are not
and they don't even call themselves
investors some of these degenerate
gamblers
do buy into this idea of like oh yeah
losing money
can make me part of the community you
know diamond hands holding on forever
can make me part of the community
this is a bad idea i mean and to hold on
as
a religion sort of well it's one thing
if
like to a certain extent i get like
early on at least when i first heard of
wall street bets
there was almost this idea of a bunch of
guys like kind of um
doing crazy things in the market and
joking about it and kind of saying look
at my horrendous losses and i
i think there was a guy who found a flaw
in how robin hood worked and
put on a map options position and like
wiped himself out
of balance in minutes you know and
that was my first impression of wall
street bets but
i i there's a lot of confused ideas i
feel around even that trade because
let's say for example if the wall street
bets guys
bought the entire float of gamestop okay
so now
gamestop is owned and managed by wall
street bets
is it worth a thousand dollars you know
the truth is that at some point
you have to sell it to someone who
actually wants to own it and they want
to own it because it's a store selling
video games
and at that point you know you you're
almost re-ipo it and and
you're going to be pitching it based on
the the business fundamentals and so
even if temporarily you can get away
from those fundamentals they always do
return now
a fundamental is this huge uh it's maybe
not a fundamental but it's a technical
fact this huge short position
did mean that the shorts did have to
cover at some point but
it becomes a little bit like uh like
being sort of knowingly invested in a
ponzi scheme or whatever where
you still have to get out before
everyone else it's kind of the greater
fool theory where you might say well i'm
buying in as a bit of a fool
and i know that it's not the best
business model in the world
i have to pass this on to someone else
so that i get out
at a fair price and that's kind of the
the problem with some of the narrative
of
sort of the the retail traders versus
wall street is that the retail
traders were in many ways the only way
some of them could win is by other ones
losing by the people eventually someone
had to buy at the top
and and lose you know be left holding
the bike so
so as sort of a post-mortem to gamestop
what do you think a lot of maybe some of
these uh the melvin capitals of the
world
are taking on to their risk analysis now
that they've
they've learned that a stock can rush up
for seemingly you know uh on a meme
stock
idea do you think anything's changing
with the way people are valuing you know
these options
or i i think a lot is changing so when i
look at um
at this effect you know one of the
things that has happened is
when we price options one of the things
that feeds into the pricing of an option
is volatility which essentially is
how much the the underlying stock can
move around
now options used to be priced all with
the same implied volatility even though
there were different strikes of options
and when the 1987 crash happened
the market fell more than people
realized it could fall in a
one-day period and what that did was it
it changed the way people price options
they realized that stocks had a
different distribution than they thought
they had
and we saw what we call the volatility
smile which basically means that
out of the money put options are more
expensive than at the money put options
and that's a bit of a
interesting technical thing now one of
the things that's happened is with
with this uh with this big squeeze in
gamestop
a lot of people have possibly realized
that stocks can crash
upwards as well as downwards like that's
really almost what happened like
to melvin capital this was the 1987
crash you know for for their positions
you know i mean they lost
half of their money in a couple of days
and
um i think an awful lot of risk
management and even just the way
derivatives are priced will will
reference this event
and people will build out risk
management that takes into account that
this sort of thing can happen again
because once it's happened once
it'll happen again and also i mean i
think i think
obviously i'm i'm sure there's there's
hundreds of
hedge funds doing sentiment analysis on
things like social media
but i wonder how much more
people are going to pay attention to
thing like like forums like wall street
bats where you might think
oh these guys maybe aren't so important
to pay attention to well
they were important enough obviously to
to cause melvin to get to lose 50 of
their capital and that's before they
grew
from like a million people on that site
to eight
whatever it is now eight million people
they've like eight eight x or
four x in size um do you think there's
gonna you're gonna see more
kind of monitoring of what retail
traders are doing from here out
i i think there'll be just more care
around it
uh you know one of the things is um
a lot of the time even the way people
make markets in stocks
the the assumption is usually that
there's something very random about the
trading of retail investors
just like that's not really an insulting
thing it just means that their buys and
sells don't mean much because when
one person's buying another is selling
so a market maker doesn't have to worry
about that
we've seen robin hood have realized that
what if all of your customers all at
once buy the same stock
and similarly a lot of hedge funds have
realized what if
all of the if a big group of people get
together and do this so
it'll have big effects on risk
management and even just
that there'll be more care taken over
what happens if retail investors become
more correlated from time to time
because
when when we'll say market makers or
brokers deal with institutions
they actually deal with them quite
differently to how they deal
with with retail investors because
they realize that there is a risk that
the big institutions might all
move together they might sort of all
have a you know attend a meeting at
davos for example and decide to do the
one thing
and so when a market maker is dealing
with institutions to actually charge
wider spreads
in order to take into account the fact
that that if they were to all move
together
that the market maker could get run over
there's sort of an adverse selection
effect that happens now that's never
been the idea with retail investors and
it's actually
why firms like citadel like dealing with
retail investors is
that you're more sure of making a profit
when there's a much more random
thing at the other end that the order
flow is more random and so
if the order flow becomes more
correlated it actually means that they
have to change the way they do business
so that's really interesting about
market makers now i mean when we talk
about retail traders
it is funny that you kind of think of
them as sort of just randomly doing
their thing
um and and it's also you know that goes
to the idea that you know
traders are these retail traders
unsophisticated most of the time are
given access to these complex financial
instruments
you know what do they not know
what are they not exposed to that maybe
uh
what do they not know that can hurt them
with options well
options are actually really really
complicated and i've seen really bright
people
get in way over their head with options
so
a good example actually around gamestop
uh someone pointed this out to me this
week
was that if you looked at back in the
20th or 21st of january
uh gamestop was trading at around 43
dollars a share okay so it's kind of
early in the squeeze we'll say um
the 10 strike april puts were trading at
33 cents so you could buy a put option
now a put option it's almost like going
short it's
it's a bet that the price will fall
below the strike price which was 10. so
you were
basically saying they would more than
quarter in price
before expiration in april and you'd pay
33 dollars for or sorry
you'd pay 33 cents for that put option
now when the price of gamestop went way
up
uh last week i think last friday when it
was at 325
those puts were trading what would you
think like if there were 33 cents
when the stock was at 43 for a bet that
it'll fall below 10
when it's at 325 you'd think they'd be
cheap
right yeah yeah yeah pennies because it
just has way more to fall
right they were more expensive they were
a dollar fifty-five
why is that well because there's a few
things that go into the pricing of a put
option
one is just the idea you know will it
fall
that's kind of the simple way and you
could say well you know
the fall from 325 to below 10 is much
more of a fault and from 43 to below 10.
right but the standard deviation of the
stock
increased wildly okay so it became it
went from a stock that didn't move
around much
to a stock that moves around an awful
lot and there's
that is one of the key inputs in pricing
options
so as it got more volatile you actually
if you owned those put options if you
had a bearish
bet on gamestop you made a 370
gain over that short period of time
that's kind of crazy and
and you have to kind of really
understand how options are priced in
order to understand that
and it actually also tells you that yes
the price was really high it was at 325
but people felt that at 325 it was maybe
more likely to fall below 10. and we
could say well
how could that happen well there's many
ways it could happen like
for example what would happen if the ceo
of gamestop decided to issue a ton of
shares right because it's at 325 it's
the best chance ever to issue shares
right
what if they issued a ton of shares and
then if it went back it wouldn't have
gone to ten dollars it would have gone
way below 10 because there were way more
shares so each share
owned less of the company there's so
many ways it could happen and it's
basically kind of what happened with
that short squeeze it was sort of you've
you've sort of stepped through the
looking glass you know you're in
in a crazy world and in a crazy world
many more things could happen than in a
calm world and so
you look at it and at 325 it's not so
crazy that it goes to a thousand and
it's not so crazy that it goes all the
way to zero
either could happen it it would have
been crazy that it goes to a thousand i
had a
i had somebody who they were insistent
that gamestop was going to a thousand
and they put their
uh they put their take profit at a
thousand dollars and they said i'm not
selling it unless
unless it goes there he said all right
no no that that's the bad thing is
i you know what there's something good
in that maybe some of these platforms
like robin hood
have attracted a youthful group into the
world of investing and actually
investing is a good way of growing your
wealth over time and there's a lot of
older people who
didn't invest and may not have great
retirements because of that so
you can say there is something good
about this sort of thing but it doesn't
work that well if people get wiped out
on their first trade or
two and that was kind of that was
something i saw back in
i started out in this business in 97 98
and the whole dot-com boom and bust
occurred and the problem was that
people my age all piled into these
dot-com stocks and they all thought they
were really smart and they
you know they looked at it and said you
know the internet's going to grow and
grow and people my age understand that
old people don't
understand it and then when
they lost you know pretty much
everything of their savings in the dot
com crash
they just moved away from investing all
together and that that's not really
something that you want to see
you know you want to see people take on
a
sort of sensible approach and just grow
their wealth over time and have a good
retirement which eventually comes for
all of us
yeah that that that is a problem with
robin hood is it is it it's attracting
new investors
obviously who've never invested before
simplifying it
but it also is maybe encouraging the
wrong types
of investments i don't know if
encouraging is the right word maybe
that's just the outcome i don't know if
you would say like implicitly their ui
is causing well
it's so interesting because there's just
really pros and cons to everything like
when
you know when i look at how much the
cost of trading has come down like i'm
able to say oh there's certain problems
with high frequency traders or whatever
possibly getting in the way of your
trades but
if you're a slow moving like kind of
sensible investor who buys a few etfs
once a month or whatever you're kind of
fine because in truth
it's way cheaper to invest now than it's
ever been before
but the problem is that when you've got
this sort of
zero cost well something that looks like
it has zero cost even though it actually
has hidden costs in it
you you end up with this problem of
people just trading trading trading and
it
it becomes like you've got sort of uh a
slot machine on your desk and you just
keep putting quarters in and pulling the
handle you know
and that's not actually good for you and
so it's
it's a very interesting thing where
there's two sides where it kind of is
you know some older guys will will tell
you like if you speak to your parents
they'll talk about back uh but you know
kind of before i was in the business um
the the stock commissions were around
five percent so every time you bought
you paid five percent to your broker and
when you sold you paid five percent to
your broker so
you're kind of down 10 to start with
which makes it way worse for investors
in the 70s and 80s than today
so in many ways it's much better but the
good thing well
i don't know that it's good to be down
10 but at least it slows you down like
you
you don't trade and trade and trade and
sort of churn your account
the way you might now because of uh
of the cheaper cost of trading
yeah that's so interesting one one thing
that i
i meant to talk about is is how luck
plays a role in giving you know new
investors
over confidence i mean there's a million
examples of this of you know
practically everybody has a story of you
know winning on some trade
all of a sudden feeling like they've got
it and then like blowing up their
account in the next
uh when they first get started but
maybe speak a little to that like let's
say you're a trader you just made a
little bit of money in gamestop you're
really kind of just like oh
i got this i kind of got this thing
figured out what would you say to those
people i mean
how can you afford that because the
market does well on this
if you've done well on this firstly take
the money set it aside
and don't expect that to happen again
because
you know i think that was even the thing
was there was a bit of a feeling a week
ago
that they'd be able to squeeze this
stock and then they'd move on you know
there was a bit of talk of silver or
there were a bunch of other
stocks that people were trying to
squeeze and
the thing is you can't get away with
this over and over again like this
was really probably a bit of a one-off
or at least it's it's a it's
it's not going to be the way we're not
going to see 20 years of a group of guys
picking a stock squeezing it making
money and moving on to the next that's
not how it's going to work yeah that's
so interesting
because i think what people have to
understand is when when
when everyone kind of publicly see a
strategy working
it gets priced into the market
right i mean people start to take these
things into account and it's no longer
as easy to uh
because people now know oh if if we have
this there's this
kind of existential risk to our short
which is this
gang of wall street bets which is like
looking for shorts to squeeze
i mean you've got to imagine at every
institution
over the last week you know the risk
managers were looking
for positions in stocks that had a high
short interest right and and
if they hadn't squeezed yet you were
told to get out of them like there's no
way they're not gonna let this
happen at least not right away again
and um it's always the you know it's
it's uh it's almost like a rule from
gambling like that if something
works you know we'll say for example if
people who know about horse bedding i
know nothing about it but i've read a
few books on the topic and what people
will tell you
is that if something works for a while
it stops working so we'll say for
example if you
did an analysis and you worked out that
just the heaviest horse always won a
race you know
what would happen is that other people
would notice as well and everyone would
start betting on the heaviest horse
and then what happens is that the
bookies odds get adjusted based upon
this betting and the same thing happens
in markets that
essentially the odds change once
everyone knows the trick
and so then all that happens is that
that thing stops working and another
thing starts working and so in markets
they just
change constantly like that and you you
just
can't expect to sort of win with the
same strategy over and over again and
it's why
people who work in markets are
constantly doing new research it's it's
not because
uh you know they'd love to do research
once and find a great thing and make a
career out of it but you don't get to do
that
right now i want to talk about that how
does that feed
to people who are still trying to run
the same strategies that were written
about in a book you know 20 years ago
i mean because that has interesting
implications somebody will say i made
this
and if you back test it back in the 80s
look how much money you would have made
that is a bit an issue though isn't it
there is a big thing with that so
when i started out in the hedge fund
industry
all of the money at the time was going
into convertible bond arbitrage that was
kind of the big
trade it was in fact the trade that
citadel made all their money on they
were
the big converts arab hedge fund at the
time and so
they had this huge success and then what
happens is a few of the star traders go
out they start up their own fund and
a few other people work it out they
start up a fund
all of the the big sort of not the
brightest institutions kind of go well
we need to be fully in
on this this convertible bond arbitrage
trade
and what happens is there aren't that
many convertible bonds out there was
kind of a niche
security and really that whole trade was
driven by wall street under pricing
convertible bonds at issue
when you went from a guy we'll say with
a billion dollars making a lot of money
on it
and suddenly 30 billion is thrown at it
the trade just stopped working so if you
look at in the early 2000s
all of the money went into convertible
bond arbitrage
right as it stopped working and then
over time you know these guys
then had to find something else to do
and you see that with many strategies
like you almost
want to avoid to a certain extent
that the thing that worked really well
in the last year or two because it's
just
it's kind of about done at that point
this is kind of the big joke i make all
the time with like core sellers actually
is that when they start selling the
course is sort of after the great period
of that industry is
over um and because it's kind of an open
secret at that point they're the one
now now that everyone's heard about it
now that you're hearing about it sort of
in the commercial
the opportunities basically has has
already gone past you by
if you're a slightly more sophisticated
trader
or an investor who are you looking
towards to get ideas
because your point is is that maybe you
shouldn't be looking at
the wall street journal for all your
trading ideas or whatever
um sort of main mainstream sources who
would you go to
you know a lot of what i do i mean
different people have different
approaches but i just really look
at what i see people doing and see if i
can find a flaw in that you know like if
you notice
that there's there's a huge group of
people who really think a certain thing
will work
you then work out firstly how that
market dynamic works and
is there a way you can profit from those
movements and so
a lot of a lot of the stuff i read i
read a lot of papers written by
academics it's kind of amazing like you
go online and you find
all of this great research that people
do and they they give it away for free
you just have to you know go to the
university websites and read what
people are studying and writing about
but also
um a lot of it is about creativity and
that's almost a funny thing that i think
pro it possibly relates to success in
almost every
industry that if you're kind of good at
copying other people that's not really a
great thing like if you
are able to just think through a problem
and say to yourself
i've got a great idea and then you have
maybe the technical skills to test that
great idea
you've got an advantage because it's all
about just coming up with new things and
coming up with ideas and
and having a lot of curiosity as to how
things work because
you're if you follow your curiosity you
might find all sorts of interesting
things that that other people haven't
paid attention to
i think actually that's a great a great
place to end it
actually follow your follow your
curiosity guys
um and don't go trading too much please
get invested in some etfs if you're
a dumb person like me just you're not
following
investing too much and by the way
following investing does not mean
watching a few youtube videos it means
studying it
uh so so yeah i think that's a good a
good general place to end it patrick
where can people find you
um well you can watch my youtube channel
which is patrick boyle
on finance and uh yeah
great and he's also he's also an
academic he's written some books you can
go check him out there
uh i don't know why anyone watches me at
this point i'm just
just trying to point you out to the
right sources of information if i can go
read a book for god's sake
we'll put a put a few links in the
description as well if
i think we mentioned a few books during
this time and um yeah
that's it thanks so much thank you it's
great fun chatting
appreciate it
i know what you need this ain't what it
seems nothing but a trick trying to sell
me on a dream but
that was where you lost me wake up and
smell the coffee
i know what you mean this ain't what it
seems nothing but a trick
trying to sell me on a dream but that
was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee you just
want my dollar bills i got this funny
feel
that what you made of who you are is
really nothing real you trying to fleece
mine
i throw a peace sign i gotta go cause
people like you i spend the least time
but coffee zilla there's nobody really
we ain't dealing with fakes and this is
the gruel killer
hit em all with the death touch oh what
a mess huh
never stop until there's